hey before you enjoy this installment of
Ash Wednesday or you may not enjoy it
frankly I don't care this is actually
the last installment of Ash Wednesday
that you'll see here on on the YouTube
because usually it's behind the paywall
from mug club members and this is mug
Club quarantine month so sign up at lot
of credit com /mo Club if you want these
shows that you've been enjoying this
month every day well you get to continue
enjoying them every day otherwise you'll
still get to get a clip here in there so
lateral credit com slash mug club
entering the promo code quarantine
you'll get $30 off we hope that we've
been here for you during this quarantine
and as we move forward after all this is
said and done we hope that you uh we
hope that you join us enjoy the show
[Music]
there's nothing I love more small
miracles then that intro song every time
guys I'm singing yeah in my head in my
heart with my hips all of it well you
just saying it out loud that's the small
miracles that our mics were turned off
I don't normally normally when I have
not taken the seat over and kick Steven
out I'm over there singing to myself
silent are you yeah it's a great happy
yeah hopping around I love it so I've
got the pipe here today we're gonna be
doing a little bit of a pair we're gonna
have a couple topics okay we have gotten
rid of whoever the guy that normally
sits here yeah yeah so what's really
long con that I plan it a disease on and
let him come all the way over here and
then gave it to Steven well he doesn't
know I gave it to him Oh community
spread yeah so alright tell me do we
have a parent we have a pairing okay it
is from mr. Brautigan oh yeah
for wrote a single barrel with an
American rebel Habano reboost oh wow
okay you know I'm gonna Matic I have no
idea whether that's a real cigar it
sounds like someone just picked no
neither words nor random generator name
thing it is a cigar but for roses single
barrel is excellent so roses the regular
the single barrel everything they make
is really really good integrate value
you know a lot of people are looking for
bourbon these days and they're like oh
well you know I'm gonna try and get
Eagle rare or you know Steven likes Wild
Turkey and you know its value they're
really good don't get me wrong
is really good right but now you've got
four roses excellent stuff so let's jump
right in yeah our first topic our first
topic is what was the last book you
finished and what are you reading now
alright so we know Arabs can't read on
Phonics work for me Oh excellent
how do you silent bath you
good work I thought I was gonna get him
no okay
what so so we're gonna go we're gonna go
best to worse here on booked well that's
definitely wait we're gonna start with
audio wave audio aid or vert of the
English language what are you reading
right now yeah right now I'm reading
Dracula nice first time reading it I'd
never gotten into it but it's so I one
thing that I've really picked up on is
how well paced it is a lot of times when
you go back to all the classics she sort
of they they don't have the same kind of
like end on a you know end on a question
kind of chapter and that kind of thing
but it's so well structured and so well
written it's written from all these
different perspectives and it's like
basically a bunch of journals and you
know yeah so it's it's written with the
structure of being a collection of
journals at the end of this kind of saga
that happens and yeah so it's been
really really good it doesn't at all
feel like there's sometimes when you
read a classic you can feel like you're
having to traverse like a river oh yeah
I'm busy yeah yeah I have to read 10 or
12 pages in order to even get something
to see it a chapter of yeah yeah yeah
but but just this one I tone wise
yeah I've also been really struck by how
really how Christian the book is I
hadn't really thought about it before I
was actually recommended by doug
tennapel a friend of mr. Garrett's here
yeah and he and he had told me that that
just really yeah I don't want to sort of
I mean obviously it's you can just spoil
it really just a lot there's a lot of
religious imagery in there that I wasn't
expecting and it was a real treat yeah
you know this reminds me of something
I'll often talk about we may have talked
about this a little bit here on the show
I think we have which is you know people
would criticize the creator of the doom
video game series to say oh it's
celebrating demonology and Satan
etcetera right but the guy who actually
create it was like have you played the
game all you do is kill demons the whole
doesn't a bad guy says we're on God's
side yeah not wait they're saying you're
not into killing demons yeah yeah if you
walked away from that
from that with like a pro demon I don't
think your pain shooting the other good
guys in doom there's something wrong
with you to protect the demon yeah
exactly
how dare you now I do enough SEC the
question in concern I think whether it's
reading or video games or any type of
media you have to expose children in an
appropriate way in in an appropriate
context so I definitely understand that
point but again in terms of pro or anti
demon I think both Dracula and doom fall
clearly on the anti demons have you read
Dracula I have okay yeah so no sock
puppets okay I'm excited to get to the
end I really am you're gonna love it
yeah so good stuff well alright so who
else who else reads here okay I'll go so
Wow last the last book that I finished
was 21 rules for the 21st century by
you've all know Harare yeah yeah
he has three books that deal kind of
with the beginning of humanity it's
called sapiens and then he has a couple
other books as well but this one talks
about a lot of really important things
that are affecting the world right now
and have been affecting us recently
including the rise of biotechnology and
AI and kind of how the world gonna deal
with it and I really found it to be not
not just you know your page-turner is
the imagery like every page is a new
idea paragraph to paragraph it's new and
interesting ideas about how we would
think about the time when should we
currently live because people will say
oh you know he asked a question oh how
many years from now will it be until a
vehicle is deciding whether or not to
kill a human being or not he will say oh
one year five years ten years some some
idiots will say 20 years but it's
actually already happened it happened 19
yeah vehicle chose to kill its own
occupant rather than go on a sidewalk to
avoid a collision where it would have
hit some other people and so we're
already in this world and it's talking
about you know what are we gonna do when
we have a class of individuals who are
not trainable to keep up with the
changes in technology and how will we
deal with that so it's a really fast
I've only kind of more recently gotten
into a lot of nonfiction books and a lot
of things that are more forward-looking
I don't know it's probably cuz I'm old
yeah
Gerald how long have you been reading
boring books I reject the premise sir
um yeah I I tend to read books that are
like that too I love learning about
things that I don't really know anything
about or have just some you know
something that's just kind of a fun
thing and I dive into different
categories for a little while and then
I'll pop back out and read somebody like
Joel C Rosenberg who writes these really
great fiction novels that have a lot of
Christian kind of threads three I'm
obviously talking about endtime stuff or
whatever maybe he's got a new one coming
out really soon so I'm very excited I
he's the guy that I read in like three
days like as soon as his book drops I'm
just reading it all the time but
recently I read the problem with
socialism which was a fantastic book and
it's like if you needed examples of why
socialism sucks
this one's but you shouldn't need them I
mean it's pretty obvious why it sucks
but this one gave you a lot of great
information on why socialism doesn't
work for people not just on the economic
side but what it does to you as a person
and so that was really good
I do remember the author's name the
author yeah I've got it on my phone
sorry I just I don't remember thomas
dilorenzo okay which there was a lot of
fun there any counter points in there
there like any moments were like yeah
you know socialism is great but only if
you were at the very top of the food
chain well it does well it doesn't just
make the case that socialism is bad like
it talks to you about what socialism
does and almost in some ways let you
kind of go okay well do I want that or
do I now want that Betances well then
these are the consequences of doing that
and you do walk away learnt like come
knowing okay well if socialism happens I
need to be at the top is good as long as
you're at the top you're fine if you're
somebody else down on one of those leg
things and they talk about it sucks and
then the next one so it kind of follows
right in this one it's called wealth and
poverty by George Gilder which is it's a
new addition for the 21st century so
there's some updating to it and it's
just it's great like fundamental
economic principles but also talking
about some of the current things that
we've seen so I'm in a financial pick
right now for summer yeah George Gilder
also has a great book called life after
Google yes I read that too that's where
I came across this one top notch really
really good it was life after Google and
he did one more that was like a life
after thing after television television
he basically predicted the the move of
entertainment and news away from TV and
back on and onto the Internet oh wow
yeah I'm so fascinating fascinating
stuff yeah George Gilder is top-notch so
where's it going after that life after
after Google yeah yeah so basically what
he what he predicts is that we moot that
they'll move a boiler alert yeah he
predicts that companies will move away
from the free service but paid
advertising model so like interruption
ads yeah as being so or moving more
towards subscription services which is
basically that's what mugs are happening
and and YouTube so YouTube you know
YouTube premium and stuff like that are
the models for life after it Google's
sowhat's yeah you heard it first here
mug Club I gotta say this because our
conversations weight off air audio eight
have been a lot about the Forgotten
depression what a 1921 yeah it's really
funny because I'm scrolling back through
and I think about a year and a half ago
I read a book by James grant called the
Forgotten depression all about 1921 and
what happened and what didn't happen did
you realize it was in that moment that
audio aid was just cribbing that book in
having no he was quoting somebody else
682 agrarian nice yeah that it knows
which one of you have the apples
quarterblack tell us what you're reading
currently right now I've started
rereading the Lord of the Rings oh wow I
miss in the first you know fellowship
the ring I haven't gotten too far in it
sure but yeah I'm just getting through
all those it's kind of three or multiple
times okay gotcha the one I recently
finished was recently last year
Lord of the Flies mmm go back go back
and read some of the ones Lord of the
dance is next it goes down well yeah I'd
like that
I like that book a lot it's very
interesting kind of how he breaks down
the kind of the psyche of a boy and I
heard that they're remaking it and
making it all about girls but it
completely destroys the whole theme of
it is are they gonna be Brian
I don't know but yeah like how how we
have this society that we live in almost
like you know all that right now
Korona stuff ish it's like you take
these elements of society out and then
they they try to create the society
themselves and then it slowly
deteriorates and yeah yeah and then the
way the book in spoiler alert is they
get the whole island gets set on fire
like all their kids are killing each
other they're chasing each other and
they chase that lead all the way down to
the beach and there's a military ship
yeah has found them and he shows up and
he's just like oh you kids your kids are
crazy let's you know I'm trying to save
you and it's kind of like the adult
looks down on the kids saying like you
you're having this crazy battle
everything is destroyed but really
they're they're an army in their society
is also doing the same thing as the
little kids are doing so I thought it
was a it's very symbolic you know I saw
the movie in college but it was still
like a cult b-movie everywhere yeah
exactly now it's spread just like the
viruses hey can I ask like a follow-up
question absolutely I've got like what
would be and I have one to answer this
question because I wanted to recommend
this book but I don't have a note here
what would be a great recommendation for
somebody to read like you're not maybe
your next book or a book that you've
read in the last year or two that you're
just like man one of my favorites that
I've read very interesting very cool
book for people to read hmm so one is
that same author you've all know Harare
he wrote sapiens it's about the the you
know it's gonna challenge your beliefs
especially a Christian you know in a
kind of our interpretation of where and
our understanding and belief about where
humanity came from right but really
understanding yeah I'm have the book I
haven't read it yet though I mean there
are a lot of things in there where I am
equally so every morning I'd read first
sites websites that are of beliefs that
typically are what the ones I don't hold
yeah and I start along there and then I
go to the other side right
yeah I'm reading a Teen Vogue I don't
believe in voguing I don't believe in
any of it no I mean I'll read CNN you
know CNN is you know if it has anything
to not do with politics
yeah I'm fairly okay we'll take you on
CNN at face-value ready to do with
pollen a whiff yeah I'm right there just
you know buckets of sodium going through
I literally go get a pretzel from down
the street at a card and I eat the
pretzel and I lick the salt off and then
I read CNN so reading sapience was in a
similar way because there were some very
interesting sociological points but also
just from a biological standpoint and
going through what I consider to be a
read straightforward full of citation
position on the history of sapiens of
Homo sapiens and the other types of and
hetero Sabian's all types all types
everyone in between
it was an okay dad joke we train through
the studio incredible I like that mr.
Rogerson we have like a little train I
actually had a follow-up question as
well but I also want to hear the answer
if anyone has one on on go ahead yes
none of my favorite books that I've read
was a man for all markets Edward Thorpe
I don't know if you guys have ever heard
him he was if you've seen the movie what
is it the Black Jack thing where the guy
comes up with the had a beat blackjack
counting Oh anyone yeah the only one but
it was based on a guy who released a
book called bringing down the house I
believe and I believe that was Edwards
Thorpe who did that and just like
phenomenally gifted person when it came
to numbers and and the markets and
everything else and so it follows his
life doing all these like that would
have been good enough like you could
just sit back the rest of your life and
be like I beat blackjack yeah you know
like I brought down the best game in
Vegas I'm done and he just kept going
from there and he he went up from there
and the things that he did but he also
it didn't have that kind of circle back
where he fails and it's horrible and
like he ended up losing his family and
you know his house blows up or none of
that happened and so you're like it's
kind of a happier ending like he kind of
went off into the sunset doing this
threat
to his life and it walks you through all
the stuffy bread really interesting very
cool but how come you didn't say spoiler
alerts
I didn't they're another terrible person
you know I'm just realizing how okay
on it let me ask an alternative question
thank you for that recommendation edward
warps when you mentioned earlier that
you had read Lord of the Rings multiple
times are there and once you guys to
think it I'll give you mine books that
you've read multiple times and I will
tell you one of the books that I have
read multiple multiple multiple times is
Ender's Game
so I've read and I've read Ender's Game
now North of 26 times did they make that
movie about that they did make resell
which I have interesting I'm scared to
see the movie er didn't my imagination
of what is happening in that book right
yeah it's probably only not nothing is
going
nothing's gonna trump that so do you
guys have any other books that you're
reading there that you've read multiple
times that you would recommend there's
so there's a book that I'm basically
always reading and it's it's book called
libel it's a book called orthodoxy by GK
Chesterton oh yeah so GK yeah that
basically in case anyone listen closely
you had the audio down which is wise
yeah there again we've got Gerald
hitting like two mating guerrillas
alright no I had Chesterton so yeah GK
Chesterton was a journalist he wrote the
he wrote the Father Brown stories a lot
of people know him from that but yeah
orthodoxy is basically it's a book yeah
it's a it's a sort of book where when
you read it the first time you underline
everything because it's all like perfect
like every every sentence you go wow I
never thought about anything that way
and then you go back to it later and you
don't remember any of it because it
because everything was so brilliant that
it basically just like washes over you
forget all about it so it's the sort of
thing that you have to reread and I've
found that with Chesterton a lot but
yeah I'm pretty much always reading that
one or always listening to it it's one
of my favorite books ever Wow amazing I
don't have to go get it
I love it excellent all right so we do
have another topic so we're gonna move
that one in our next topic is if you
could only listen to two albums for the
rest of your very short or on a virus
life what be Carol I know
alright so def leppard pyromania pretty
good when they have I mean like five or
six of their best songs were on that one
yeah yeah very very good and then I
don't think in somebody correct me if
I'm wrong I don't think Coldplay has
like a greatest hits album that I know
of I would do that if that was out I
would do that maybe they do and I just
have never seen it but if not I would
pick rush of blood to the head someone's
got some like mixed USB out there with
one but I'm several I mass-marketed so
that they would be those two Coldplay is
like you know I got my 80s stuff which
for some reason I love even though I
didn't love it when I was you know in
the 80s I went back and started liking
it's kind of like it and Coldplay as we
know is the greatest rock band you know
world as the movie yesterday said it's
not Coldplay it's not fix you ladies and
gentlemen contain the Coldplay virus
locking the doors and burning this
entire studio to the ground yeah yeah
it's probably safe okay thank you
god save the yeah gerald seriously you
have Arab League okay ten greatest bands
in history what criteria are you using
good criteria you don't like them and
that's fine I don't I don't like the
Beatles and I know they're a top-ten
band in history right look I'm gonna
tell you my repairing a terrible taste
in everything but I have better taste
you know this is your own personal hell
that you have to live in the rest your
life but it's true album so I mean
Nickelback if that's know what
hey hey hey if the choices are between
cutting yourself Alyssa Nickelback I'm a
private
yeah but some people might use nickel
bank instead right
don't use Nickelback and then cut it off
no sweet without the sour and Nickelback
assets our alright audio way to albums
so racist it's hard to narrow it down to
two if I had two that literally is the
badness of the question you were yes I
have to I have to so I probably Paul
Simon's Graceland I think that's I think
that's got to be number one okay and
then maybe it would either be another
side of Bob Dylan one of the early Bob
Dylan records and Jackson Browne late
for this guy I don't know it's it's
that's kind of my stuff so I it would be
really hard to choose between those
three but something like that you're a
sweet guy we're gonna hf3 in this
fictional universe you you got third
album alright quarterblack
tell us all about your - as everybody
knows I love coding cambria so yeah it
was about being secrets of silent
earth-three is one of my picks
okay and my second would be I can't
remember the name I think it's Texas
flood my Stevie Ray Vaughn know I know
they have a song I think the whole album
was named that if not just the greatest
hits mm-hmm no no rat hmm I'm
interesting I'm serious Gerald I every
time I think there's no way that Gerald
could be a more racist then all of a
sudden I imagine there's a little music
video where I mean I can't remember what
the song is not but I think so John
where as a dancing asian guy and he's
humping the air so hard he slams through
the ground and the whole videos like
people dancing even more to slam through
more floors of this apartment building
down and down and down a downtown and
that's you okay me yeah if I could only
listen to two albums with my terrible
taste Tupac
the first one would be little a little
cheating here
Creedence Clearwater okay Greatest Hits
all right it's not really it was offered
it was real it wasn't a mixtape yeah I
like it right there are so many songs
that every time they come on I think man
I'm in a good mood
yeah it's great yeah amazing stuff a lot
and here's the thing that came to my
mind when I was thinking about this
criteria is there are a whole range of
emotions that music helps to either
bring you into or to help you out of
yeah absolutely and I think there's a
broad variety of music on that
particular album my second album would
be jagged little pill mm-hmm Alanis
Morissette really yes there's a lot of
like grain lot of emotion early things
greatly album yeah the first one 90s
yeah that was yeah eight an ironic
commercial success yeah yeah a song you
oughta know
and then Rio you ought to know yeah
amazing stuff you can share would you go
down on him in a theater one of the
lyrics oh my god you guys are terrible
I chose okay so here's some questions
some questions I was in college I worked
at I worked at a company that was in the
firearms industry and I had a gentleman
who I worked for in a particular
department who told me he had made all
of this a particular company and a
gentleman in a particular department I'm
just gonna let it rise so respect for
him and I thought he had really good
focus at work and Sara and I said some I
was like hey like you know what are you
always listening to every day our music
and he said I'm listening to this one
album called December and it's just
instrumental Christmas and him music
from the kind of winter holidays and
Christmas holidays yeah and and he's
like here let me give you a copy and I
still have the same copy that he gave me
though I've now downloaded to put it on
my phone but whatever I need to like
crank out work I put on this
instrumental Christmas music yeah all
year round and I just get in the zone
yeah like if I had a montage you know
instead of eye of the tiger it would be
this December but that's a thing like
sometimes you need your brain like you
know classical music is a great thing to
work - yeah for me it's Coldplay I used
to listen to Coldplay know like counting
cash because I used to run a race track
up in Ohio and I would count 20 to
30,000
it would take like seven or eight hours
to allocate it to the right places drug
money is what it sounds like no but I
would listen to Coldplay and so now when
I listen to it doesn't distract me at
all I can do whatever work or whatever
focus that I need to so that's my
description of yours yeah I will say
though Gerald as a lawyer I do I'm not
your lawyer yet I recommend you not talk
about your money laundering process yeah
yeah I filled out all the paperwork I
walked into a bank with $100,000 in a
duffel bag and they're like can you come
around the counter please
I could have been hit like easily and
the money taking honey okay let me grab
a pen what track was this I was a part
owner of Lorain County Speedway up in
Ohio right it was a three it's my last
fault high banked racetrack
nascar-sanctioned one of 100 in the
country yeah race I didn't race but I
jumped in a car every once in a while
just for fun when the track was gotcha
you were the bela check nothing I did
yes exactly but I did compete in the
demolition derby which all kinds of fun
that was fun yes incredible I like it
well so those are our topics for the day
super excited the to hear all the
different comments we could have from
people so go ahead and post at s Crowder
tell us about your albums that you're
listening to and if you had only two did
you could listen to two go ahead and
tell tell us all here at the show tell
Steven what those are and if you have
any great books that you want your
fellow mug clubbers and other fans of
louder's Crowder to listen to or read
whether you're doing audible or the old
paperback go ahead and post those as
well and we'll see you next time
[Music]
you
[Music]